>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Jon Parrish Peede: Hello.
On behalf of my colleagues
at the National Endowment
for the Humanities, I am pleased to
be with you, and our agency is proud
to be a contributor to the National
Book Festival which is hosted
by the Library of Congress and
it is now in its 17th year.
And thanks are due to David M.
Rubenstein, who is the co-chairman
of the festival and also
to the many volunteers.
And also, this pavilion is here
through the generosity
of Wells Fargo.
And also, could we
just take a moment
and recognize the Librarian
of Congress.
Could you just join me in
acknowledging Doctor Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> It's wonderful to
see so many book lovers
of all ages and all walks of life.
Before this starts, I want to
ask you out of consideration
of your fellow audience
members to please turn off
or silence your cell phones.
There's nothing worse than hearing
one ringing in these events,
except for the fact that it
is ringing in your own pocket.
Again, if you might do that, it
would be very much appreciated.
It is my great pleasure to
introduce A. Scott Berg,
a Pulitzer prize-winning
biographer and editor
of the NEH supported
Library of America volume,
"World War I in America: Told
by the Americans Who Lived It."
And here's the book.
It's a beautiful book,
an exquisite book.
It's for sale here, and I
hope at the end of this,
that you will join the
author for the signing.
I have some notes about Scott's
biography and I'll share that,
and then I want to say a little bit
about the trade of
being a biographer.
Berg is the perfect
choice for this book.
His first book won the
National Book Award and was
about an editor, Maxwell Perkins.
And of course, you know Perkins as
the editor for F. Scott Fitzgerald,
for Ernest Hemingway among others.
He also wrote a biography
of Charles Lindbergh
and it also won the Pulitzer Prize.
And of course, he has written a
biography of Woodrow Wilson as well.
And that very much ties into
what we're talking about today,
World War I on the
hundredth anniversary of it.
And I want to say a bit about
the craft of being a biographer.
Think about what it takes.
You have to be a researcher.
You have to be an editor.
You have to be an author.
You must have a point of view
but you must not be a partisan.
You must provide a vista for the
reader to have a view of history
without narrowing the range
of the reader's vision.
That's a rare gift, and there are at
any time in any great nation only 10
or 20 people really, I think,
operating at the height
of the craft, and we are about
to hear from one such person.
So please join me in
welcoming Scott Berg.
[ Applause ]
>> A. Scott Berg: Thank
you very much.
That was a wonderful introduction.
I'm most appreciative.
And I want to thank the National
Endowment of the Humanities as well,
which has been a great supporter
of the Library of America
which published this book and
has been a great supporter
of this book in particular.
This book represents something
quite special, certainly to me,
and I hope to all of you ultimately.
Because we are celebrating,
in a way,
two anniversaries with this book.
The first is, this is
the 35th anniversary
of the Library of America.
I don't know if you know
about the Library of America.
If you don't, I don't know what
you've been doing for 35 years.
You should know this organization.
They publish America's greatest
writers in affordable, attractive,
authoritative, uniformly
bound books.
If you pick the greatest
authors in America
and what they do will actually
8 to 10 volumes a year.
I would just add as a plug for them,
they make wonderful wedding gifts,
birthday gifts, anniversary
gifts, bar mitzvah gifts.
So one size fits all.
And I urge you if you haven't
seen a Library of America book,
to go online and check out
the Library of America.
Usually they come in these
lovely little black tuxedos,
really just sort of
beautiful black jackets.
But every now and then, they do
a specialty book not on an author
but on a subject, and such is the
case with the book that disappeared
from there which is
the World War I book
that I was selected
to be the editor of.
The second anniversary,
as Jon just pointed
out in his a kind introduction, is
this is the hundredth anniversary
of America's entry into
the First World War.
I think World War I is the most
important and most forgotten event
in modern history, at least if
you live in the United States.
It is not that way if you're in
Europe or other parts of the world.
But here in America it is.
We all know the date 9/11.
We all know December 7, 1941.
In some ways we should
also know April 6, 1917.
Now it's true, America
was not invaded that day.
We were not attacked on that day.
But it is a day in
which we went to war.
And I think the results
of our entering that war,
that great conflagration
that is World War I,
had repercussions arguably
greater than those other two dates
that I've already listed.
So what I'm going to do for the next
few minutes here is kind of talk
about my volume here
that I was asked
to put together about World War I.
And I also want to discuss some
of the impact that World War I had
on the United States
and had on the world.
Now, here was my task.
The Library of America came to
me and asked if I'd be interested
in editing a volume on World
War I as seen through the eyes
and the writings of Americans.
And was also meant to be
all nonfiction writing.
Now, that threw me a little
because World War I created some
of the greatest fiction this
country has ever produced,
the likes of Hemingway
and Fitzgerald
and Faulkner and Dos Passos.
So I'm going to do a
book on World War I
but I'm not even going
to mention those people.
I'm going to do nonfiction.
And then I thought, well great,
there's been some fabulous
nonfiction written by the likes
of Barbara Tuchman, "The
Guns of August" and so forth.
"No, we don't want
any of those either.
We don't want books that
were written after the fact."
We want nonfiction that was
written as the war was going on."
So here is the task -- to
select some 100 to 150 pieces
that will chronicle, that will
narrate, the story of World War I,
we hope in its entirety
in every way.
And in so doing, show a selection
of the greatest American
writing from those years.
So this was a daunting task.
It began with -- I actually
had a wonderful team
of historical advisors.
I a wonderful team of editors
of the Library of America,
and I think we probably started
with several thousand
pieces to play with.
And then we just kept winnowing it
down until we were
down to a few hundred.
And then the editors of the Library
of America and I went through
and looked for those pieces
that most significantly, again,
addressed the two points --
displayed excellent American writing
and be illustrated -- chronicle
what was going on in the war.
Now, wars are just on battlefronts.
Wars are fought at home as well.
And so the object of this book
was to try to capture, you see,
what was going on domestically
as well as universally
as this war was being fought.
So here was the task again.
Sure, I knew I was going to
begin with some great reportage.
And fortunately, World
War I has some
of the greatest reporters
who have ever written.
I mean, the likes of Richard
Harding Davis, Floyd Gibbons,
John Reed whom you may
know from the movie "Red."
How about Nellie Bly?
She was a fantastic
reporter, often forgotten.
It would probably surprise most
of you as it surprised me to learn
that Edith Wharton wrote some
of the greatest reportage
of World War I that's
ever been done.
I mean, here's Edith Wharton,
famous for the "Age of Innocence"
and her other novels of society New
York at the turn-of-the-century,
and yet there she was at the
front lines in Belgium and France,
sending reports back of
what this war was all about.
Some of the most eloquent
politicians ever were charming in,
needless to say, on the war, the
likes of William Jennings Bryan,
Eugene Debs, and so forth.
Justices -- Oliver Wendell Holmes
was writing during World War I,
perhaps the greatest
writer ever to sit
on the court, certainly one of them.
And yet, he had much to say because
there was so much legal activity
that was going on in the country, in
the world, that had to be dealt with
and had to be discussed,
most particularly alien
and sedition laws.
But I also wanted to
include songwriters.
What were the songs
that were being sung?
Because often, they
crystallize the feelings
that are being expressed
during the war.
I wanted comedy.
I wanted the jokes of the period.
And wouldn't you know, the first
political standup comedian was
during World War I.
He was a cowboy from Oklahoma
who used to get out on a stage
with a rope and he
would just twirl it.
And as he would twirl it, perform a
few rope tricks, he would tell some
of the most biting political
satire, often with the President
of the United States sitting
right in front of him.
He was the first to do it,
Woodrow Wilson, by the way,
was the first president to listen
to those jokes in a theater
and he loved them, by the way.
And then I wanted to capture the
voices of soldiers, needless to say.
I wanted those soldiers
who had been farmers,
who had suddenly been brought
over to the battlefront.
Mechanics -- and I learned
something quite interesting,
which was this was a period that
wasn't necessarily great literacy,
even the least schooled people,
especially the young man,
the farmers and the mechanics and
so forth, who went overseas to fight
in World War I, even they
were well-versed in the Bible
and they knew their Shakespeare.
And so, I would find
in diaries and letters
of the most common Americans the
most uncommon language and thoughts,
and they really expressing
some just fantastic sentiments
in the most beautiful language.
I wanted to get somebody like,
for example, the Army captain
from Independence Missouri,
Harry Truman,
who was sending love letters
back to his sweetheart,
Bess Wallace in Missouri.
You see what his letters
especially brought home to me,
and there are some wonderful
letters written just days before the
armistice, in fact, which
are included in the volume.
But what interested me about
it is when we read history
of World War I, we
all know how it ends.
But when you're reading diaries
and letters and reportage
as the story is unfolding,
those authors didn't know what
the ending was going to be.
They didn't know what the results
of this battle was going to be.
They didn't know what was
going to happen tomorrow.
And so, there's a kind
of electricity
that really runs throughout
this entire volume
and was really quite exciting.
And then, of course, I had to play
with the man I consider the
greatest voice of the age,
and that is Woodrow Wilson.
And I think ultimately this is why
the Library of America asked me
if I would help put this book
together, if I would edit it
and write an introduction to
it and write the headpieces
for the 130 selections
we have in the book.
And that is because
Wilson was the great voice,
he was the engine behind this era
and he was certainly the engine
behind the United States going
to war.
And he was, as it happens, not only
the most educated president we have
ever had to this day, he is
the only president we've had
who not only got a bachelors degree
but then studied law
and then he got a PhD.
He is, to this day, our
only president with a PhD.
But he also was extremely eloquent.
And they're just two or three
other presidents I would put
in the same category.
I don't want to shortchange
Lincoln, Thomas Jefferson,
but Woodrow Wilson is definitely in
the top tier of American presidents
and I would also add -
and this is most important
for the book I was
putting together --
Woodrow Wilson is the
last president we had
who wrote every word that he spoke.
He did not work with speechwriters.
So when you see a Woodrow
Wilson speech,
that meant Woodrow Wilson
sat down and wrote it.
And what I mean, he
sat down and wrote it,
I mean not with a secretary.
I mean he sat down
with a shorthand pad
because he knew how to do shorthand.
He would write his first
drafts in shorthand and then,
because he was probably the
best typist in the White House,
he then typed his rough drafts and
then he would make notes on them.
And then he might give
them to somebody else
to type, but generally not.
So these are the voices
I had to play
with in putting this book together.
Now, as I was gathering all these
pieces, I began to see I knew I had
to write an introduction
for the piece to kind
of condense the entire World
War into 10 or 15 pages.
But I noticed a theme that I
hadn't seen discussed before
that I think is extremely important.
And it is this -- I think World
War I in large measure was
about the subject of identity.
The war got started
in Europe in 1914
because there were
really four great empires
that owned so much of the world.
And these empires, some
of them were so huge
that they really embraced
communities that had nothing to do
with each other, nationalities,
creeds, races.
And they were so far apart just
geographically, to say nothing
of morally, historically, socially,
every which way you might want
to slice and dice these
particular empires.
And so, I began to see, and in fact
the assassination of an archduke
that ignited World War I
was by somebody saying,
"I don't really feel as though
I'm in Austro-Hungarian.
There are Serbs, and we want
to be treated a certain way,
and Bosnians a certain way."
And so, that's what
tripped off to war,
this feeling that people were
searching for their identities.
Europe went to war of course because
then there is a great feeling
of militarism, especially
in Germany.
There was a great rising
tide of nationalism.
So nationalism is really
nothing more
than the expression of
identity, of course.
And then there was a system
of alliances that kicked in.
There had been treaties made over
the prior centuries and decades
that made it so that once
war broke out somewhere,
another country was going to come in
and another country in retaliation.
And the next thing you
knew, the world was at war.
And so, that really brings
in to mind what is the
United States supposed to do?
Here is the United
States, a country thousands
of miles away, buffered by an ocean.
We're quite safe here.
But the United States
is now a teenage nation.
It's in its 13th or 14th decade.
And what is the United States'
role, if any, in this war abroad?
As the world is shrinking, as
communications, as transportation,
is making it so that some event that
happens in the middle of Germany
or in the middle of the
Austro-Hungarian Empire is going
to have some affect on
what's going on in St. Louis
or New Jersey or California.
So all these things
had to be considered.
The president of the United
States had a very firm feeling.
Woodrow Wilson thought the United
States should stay out of this war,
that it really did not
involve the United States
or at least it shouldn't
involve us militarily.
And so, he thought the best thing
we could do was remain neutral,
not just militarily but
even in thought, he said.
Because the United
States, of course,
is made up of German-Americans,
Russian-Americans,
English-Americans.
So which side are we meant to be on?
And ultimately, he was arguing for
something called Americanism --
that we should just be
Americans, that this was a moment
and this is an identity
question where Wilson was arguing
for the fact that the United States
should get rid of its hyphens
and that we should now
just become Americans.
So this was a great, great thing,
and this is largely, as I said,
what my introduction is about.
And in the 130-odd
pieces in the book,
you will just see it just
happened to be that this thread
of identity just keeps running
through it, personal identity,
national identity, and even
identity as human beings.
Who are we?
So what happened was, as
the war kept going on,
there was the great
debate in this country.
You know, the United
States has had a couple
of great debates in its lifetime.
The first one was obviously when
the nation was being foundered
and the revolution,
the Federalist Papers
that forged the Constitution
and a country.
We had another great debate
in this country from the 1840s
on until really the
Civil War came about.
And that was yet another
identity issue.
Are we in fact United States here?
That was one.
We had a great debate
during World War II.
Should this country go to war.
This is just before Pearl Harbor
when the America First
Movement really took off
between 1939,1840 into 1941.
Was it America's role to go
to war and fight overseas,
either in Asia or in Europe?
But one of the great debates - Oh,
Vietnam was obviously another
important great debate.
But one of the most
interesting of the great debates,
if not the most interesting, was
the great debate about World War I,
because we had not been attacked.
And this became a debate
about ideas.
What is the role of
the United States?
What is our identity?
What are we meant to do?
And I hear the voice of
Woodrow Wilson yelling at me.
"No Scott, it's not ideas.
It's ideals."
And Woodrow Wilson, for three years,
believed, as I said, we should stay
out of this war as the likes
of Teddy Roosevelt was arguing
to bring us into the war.
And gradually, Wilson who was a
great Anglophile himself but tried
to live up to his own
rule of neutrality,
found that we just couldn't
look the other way any longer.
And when he saw what was going
on in Belgium, when he saw --
and I hope you read Edith
Wharton's dispatches from Belgium --
and when he saw the hideous things,
the atrocities that were going
on in this war, gradually
Wilson believed, "No,
this is something we
better start preparing for."
And as the years went on, 1914,
1915, it's now up to 1916.
Woodrow Wilson got reelected on the
slogan, "He kept us out of war,"
and that was a very good thing.
But by the time he was
inaugurated in March 1917,
something had been released
called the Zimmerman Telegram
which was this secret
document that revealed
that Germany was then colluding
with Mexico, trying to get them
into the war to come to fight
against the United States,
promising them territories back if
they would come in with Germany.
And that was really a
kind of tipping point
for the United States
and for Woodrow Wilson.
And on April 2, 1917,
Woodrow Wilson gave a speech
that I think is the single most
important foreign policy speech
in American history, because in
that speech Woodrow Wilson famously
implanted a single sentence.
And that sentence is, "The world
must be made safe for democracy."
Now, when he said that to a
joint session of Congress,
at first they didn't know
what he meant exactly.
But in a second or two,
they realized what it meant
and they burst into huge applause.
And that's line, whether
you understand it or not,
whether you agree with it or not,
whether you believe it or not,
has been the bedrock of
all American foreign policy
for the last hundred years.
Every incursion by the
United States anywhere
since that time has really been
based on that single principle,
that single sentence of making
the world safe for democracy.
Is that nation building?
That is to be decided.
That line, "The world must
be made safe for democracy,"
has often been used by presidents.
It has often been abused
by presidents.
Again, like it or not, it has been
what has compelled the United States
to take action for 100 years.
What Wilson was basically trying
to state and what he was adding
to the formula here
was a moral component
to American foreign policy.
And he was basically saying,
"How can we, the United States,
look at what is happening
to Belgium.
Germany trampling over this tiny
country for the simple reason
that it stood between
Germany and France
and they had to get across it.
Ad they conquered it.
They burned it.
They did terrible things
to the Belgians,
who did nothing to bring it on.
And what was happening elsewhere
in Europe, mostly at the hands
of the Hun as the German was known,
that became compelling enough
to Wilson to lead us into this war.
That now, part of the
American identity, you see,
was to be a great champion
of democracy.
And so it was.
Now, in this moment,
the United States
of America was a neutral country.
We had a standing army of
about 150,000 soldiers.
If you made a list of all the armies
of the countries of the world,
we were somewhere around 16 or 17.
We were somewhere between
Portugal and Serbia.
That's who the United States was.
And now, over the next
year or two, Woodrow Wilson
as commander-in-chief, intended to
change that and turn this country
into the greatest fighting
force the world had ever seen.
And that's what he did.
Over the next few years, he
mobilized some 4 million young men,
most of whom were in the Army,
but we also then needed a Navy
to transport all those
soldiers overseas.
This was the moment that a
sleeping giant basically awakened
and became the first
modern superpower.
Now, I mentioned that this
Great War is happening overseas.
It's happening mostly in France
and Belgium having been trod upon.
So there's France just
getting shut up,
and it took a while before
we could muster an army
and send them over there.
In that period, the war was
really being fought here at home.
And this is the moment where
America really goes to war,
because the American
identity changed
so dramatically over the next year.
And here are just some
takeaways for you.
You know, when I said how
impactful World War I was,
here are some examples of what we
live with today because of something
that happened a hundred years ago.
This is the moment that the
federal government went really big.
In order to wage a war on the scale
that Woodrow Wilson felt we had to,
we suddenly had an alphabet soup.
We had thousands of
boards, agencies,
committees, and commissions.
Woodrow Wilson hired the
biggest men in American business
to form committees,
a war trade board
that was headed by Bernard Baruch.
This was really the beginning,
although they didn't use this term.
This was generally the beginning
of a military-industrial
complex in this country.
It was also a moment
strangely 's that was very good
and important for the Jews.
Not just American Jews,
but Jews around the world,
there was something called the
Balfour Declaration which called
for a national home
for the Jewish people,
something that is being discussed
in the British Parliament.
And Wilson's advisors advised him
not to have anything to do with it.
Don't make any comment.
But Wilson said, "Too late.
I already made it very clear.
I support this declaration."
And so, in essence, in 1917 the
United States really became the
first country beyond
Britain and Palestine itself
to acknowledge the fact that
there should be a national home
for Jewish people.
The economy changed drastically.
Now, Woodrow Wilson did
not invent the income tax
but he certainly modernized it,
and what had once been 1% on $3000
of income doubled to 2% on $1000.
Surtaxes were levied,
some as high as 67%.
There were war profits
taxes that were introduced.
So you now see this great
infusion of federal government.
You know, to this day,
there are some people --
I've heard it on TV --
the likes of Glenn Beck.
I remember he once did a list
of the worst people in history,
and there was Hitler and
Mussolini and Stalin.
And there at the top of the
list, he had Woodrow Wilson.
And it was because, I think,
of what he felt Wilson had done
to this nation by making
this huge federal structure
that was basically
not going to go away.
Indeed, the federal deficit went
from $1 billion to $9 billion.
We had war bonds.
You know, during the election
season, we often hear about
and think about and see Hollywood
joining hands with Washington.
The first link in that relationship
was actually made during World War I
when Wilson called upon movie stars.
This was a brand-new phenomenon.
Movie star, silent film stars,
Mary Pickford, Charlie Chaplin,
Douglas Fairbanks, William S.
Hart the great stone-faced cowboy
in silent pictures.
They went out and actually
went to rallies
and raised money for war bonds.
There was something that Wilson
introduced to the Congress,
something called a debt ceiling.
This began as a tool for the
United States Treasury Department
so that Wilson didn't have to go
to Congress each time he
wanted to float a bond.
He just said to the Congress,
"Why don't you set a debt ceiling,
and whenever we need
to float another bond,
maybe we'll raise the debt ceiling.
We'll see what happens with that."
And the fact, the Army and Navy,
of course, built up, as I told you,
from some 100,000-150,000
to 4 million.
The Navy went from
60,000 to 500,000.
We had a selective service
system for the first time.
Now, this meant that there was
a local board in every community
that was going to determine
which of its young men were going
to be going overseas.
This matter ultimately
that a Harvard scion,
some rich kid from Massachusetts,
might be sharing a trench, you see,
with some farm boy from Missouri.
So this really shook up the economy.
Wars are game changers.
They just shake up all the pieces
and you see how it settles down.
And it really affected
another part of American life
that had long been
overlooked or dismissed,
and that was the African
American, the black man, the Negro.
There were still segregated units,
trenches, and burials for blacks
who wanted to serve, and they
did suffer twice the death rate
that the white soldiers did.
But in fact, some 40,000
African Americans did go overseas
and took part in combat.
They didn't always fight
shoulder to shoulder.
In fact, they did not
with white soldiers,
but they were at least
on the same side.
Now, as a result of this,
several things happened.
Because they were shorthanded
in the South especially,
there was a migration of
African Americans moving north.
And then perhaps the greatest
thing that happened as result
of World War I is in the aftermath.
Because, you know, African
Americans had a real dilemma.
Why should we be going overseas?
Why should we be fighting for
peace and freedom for Belgians
when we don't really have peace or
freedom here in the United States
when we are second if not
third class citizens?"
So it was a real decision for an
African American to go overseas.
But by and large the thinking was,
we must do it because we will come
back as full-fledged Americans.
Our mothers will see sons
shedding the same blood
that white mothers do.
Some of us may not come home,
but this is an opportunity for us
to win our red badges of courage
and to come back as Americans.
And they did come back, and
unfortunately they discovered
that they were treated
just as badly,
if not worse, than before they left.
And this actually, I think, is the
darkest mark against Woodrow Wilson
in his entire presidency.
And that is, Woodrow Wilson, our
educator-in-chief, our smartest man
who has ever been in the White
House, he was a Southerner,
and he did have more
than racist tendencies.
But this was a moment when all these
soldiers came home that I think he,
being a Southerner and a
somewhat reconstructed racist,
could have said to America, "These
men have fought just the way
that white men have fought,
and we must now embrace
them in American society."
And in fact, he said
nothing on the subject.
And as a result of it,
in 1919 we had something
that we now call the Red Summer.
And it was called the Red Summer
because there was so much bloodshed.
Riots broke out in two dozen
cities and they were horrific.
They were really terrible.
But really coming out of the ashes
of these riots is the
civil rights movement.
It really gets born as a
result of the First World War.
The labor situation
changed to such an extent
that even women were welcome
to take jobs outside the home.
It was a concept we had seen signs
of before, but we had never seen it
in any seriously measurable numbers.
But now, women were taking
jobs outside the home.
There were bad statistics
in the beginning,
but let me put it this way.
Even black women no longer had
to work merely as domestics.
They could get jobs as elevator
operators or cafeteria waitresses.
And the other thing that happened
for women during this period
is that they got the vote.
And they got the vote because
Woodrow Wilson went to Congress
and said, "You know what?
Suffrage, this is now
a wartime measure."
And he went to Congress and he
said, "We cannot really be fighting
for peace and freedom abroad
when half our own subjects do not
have this the ability to vote,
to have a say in what
the government is."
And so, he argued extensively,
and as soon as the war was
over, women did get the vote.
Now, you've got 4 million soldiers
and you've got people
starving all over Europe.
You've got to feed all these people,
and America in that moment becomes
the great breadbasket of the world.
The way some of the European
countries were using food
as a weapon, blockades
keeping people
on the continent from getting food.
The United States realized we
could use food as a great tool,
and indeed we really
began to feed the world.
We became the great
breadbasket of the world.
We went on next hours each day.
You know what?
Every year we have
daylight savings time.
That's because of World War I.
It all goes back to that
because Woodrow Wilson figured
if we have an extra hour of
sunlight every day, we can harvest
that much more food every day.
Well, the United States,
of course, won the war.
We finally got into it, actually
fighting in the spring of 1918.
Within six months, the
war was fought and won
because the United States
troops, they not only proved
to be a very good fighting machine,
but they were fresh soldiers
after this battle had
just been going on.
It was a real stalemate until
the American soldiers got in.
Wilson brought us into the First
World War because he believed
if we got in, we could
help write the peace.
And Wilson had a great plan
for the future of the world.
That's all.
Wilson narrowed it
down to 14 points,
and some of them were quite
specific about borders
and some were general
things about the seas
and the laws that govern the world.
But he had one important point,
and that was his 14th point,
which was the creation of something
he called a League of Nations.
And Woodrow Wilson believed if every
country would sign on to the League
of Nations and agreed to sit
down at a table with each other
and they must bring any
disagreements they have
to this table before they
would ever go to war.
Because if you did go to war against
a country in the League of Nations,
you would be facing everyone
else in the League of Nations.
In essence, Woodrow Wilson was
introducing collective security.
This comes out, you
see, of World War I.
And self-determination, that was
one of the keys to the 14 points,
that every country around
the world should be able
to determine its own
political future.
The results of the
war were enormous.
We won this war.
It changed the American personality.
Suddenly the United States became
a genuinely extrovert nation.
Belgium was restored, Alsace was
returned, Poland was recognized.
There were lots of problems with
the 14 points with the treaty
that was ultimately signed in
Versailles, the most important
of which was done at the
very last minute really,
when some agreement was made
that gave Japan a great
advantage over China.
And as a result of that,
there was a huge outburst
in China on May 4, 1919.
It was really the beginning, the
seeds of a revolution over there.
And it incited the likes of a
very young man named Mao Tse-Tung
and a whole generation
of young Chinese,
largely students I might add,
really became the generation
that created the Great
Revolution in China.
And as a result of that, you
see, I think the tentacles
of World War spread everywhere.
Now, I'm going to leave you
with one reading from the book,
one very brief reading
from this book
that I put together on World War I.
It's something that Woodrow Wilson
said on Memorial Day, May 30, 1919.
The treaty hadn't yet been signed.
Everything had been discussed.
Everything had been agreed upon.
Just a few details
remaining to be settled.
And on Memorial Day, Woodrow
Wilson and his wife drove
out to an American
cemetery just outside Paris.
It was close enough to Paris that
you can actually see the spoke
of the Eiffel Tower
off in the background.
And there, Woodrow Wilson walked
out before hundreds of thousands
of graves, the white crosses.
You've seen pictures
of it time and again.
And Woodrow Wilson, who could
barely contain himself --
there were lots of French mothers
and families scattered
all around this.
But this was an American cemetery
and the French had planted an
American flag at every grave.
And Wilson got out there and
he did a very eloquent speech.
The speech was finished,
they fought.
And then, Wilson said -- this
is hard for me to read --
"If I may speak a personal word.
I beg you," he said to his
audience, "to realize the compulsion
that I myself feel that I am under.
By the Constitution
of our great country,
I was the commander-in-chief
of these men.
I advised the Congress to
declare a state of war.
I sent these lads over here to die.
Shall I, can I, ever speak a word
of counsel which is inconsistent
with assurances I gave
them when they came over.
It is inconceivable there is
something better, if possible,
that a man can give than his life,
and that is his living spirit
to a service that is not easy.
To resist counsels that are hard to
resist, to stand against purposes
that are difficult to stand
against, and to say, 'Here stand I,
consecrated in spirit to the
men who were once my comrades
who are not gone and who have
left me under internal bands
of fidelity.'" I often wish every
president had to read that paragraph
of that speech before he
sends any man or woman abroad.
So, we live in a world and
especially a country whose economy,
whose entire foreign policy,
you see, our identity was forged
by this war, by World War I.
And I think taking a
cue from Woodrow Wilson,
it behooves us never to forget that.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.